Speaker 1: Let's go to Victor from California.
Victor, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Did you hear it?
Yes, I can.
I just want to kind of go over and ask what
you thought about this idea of fake news,
do you think that kind of.
And by the way, I'm a big fan of your show.
Another kind of commentary shows.
Thank you, YouTube.
But do you think what we're doing or what
kind of this move towards hard news, towards
more commentating news is kind of creating
more of this cloud of fake news in the world?
Speaker 1: I don't think I you said the move
towards hard news and commentating news.
Those are two different accounts.
Speaker 4: Guess, right.
So right now, when you look at the media,
for example, if you go to Fox News or you
go to CNN, a lot of it is is kind of news
interwoven with commentary.
So they will report on the fact, the report
on an event that actually is happening, for
example, if like, say, a president is proposing
some new legislation or he's signing into
law something, yeah, they'll report that event
and then they'll make some kind of commentary
on it.
Right.
And if I'm a viewer watching this, what I'm
already doing is I'm already kind of looking
at what are listening to what's happening
and getting a kind of subjective experience.
Sure.
So if I'm a conservative and I watch Fox News
or CNN, for example, and there's some news
being reported on and then there's common
commentary, some kind of commentary that I
don't agree with, I'll just automatically
assume that it's fake news.
And the same goes with a liberal watching
Fox News.
And so the that moving towards the hard news
to more kind of commentary and commentary,
both from the left and right, kind of increases
this world of not only echo chambers, but
this idea of fake news.
Speaker 1: So your questions your question
is kind of complicated and I only sort of
understand it.
But let me tell you a couple of different
things.
One, a lot of people, if it if it's packaged
like a news show, they think it's just news.
Right.
So you look at Fox in the morning and then
you see Tucker Carlson at night and it looks
pretty damn similar.
So you're like, this is all news when it's
really not.
The other problem is there will be commentary
even in shows that are supposed to be just
news shows.
That's that's another issue.
And a lot of people aren't able to sort of
suss that out.
And then the same applies to online stuff.
You look at websites for fake news news sites
and real news, and they look almost identical.
People can't tell the difference.
So I don't know that the problem is necessarily
that you're seeing the mix of news and opinion,
although you can argue that that is part of
the problem because of how ignorant people
are.
But really, the problem is the lack of media
literacy and the lack of people who can think
critically about what they're watching.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Do you think, though, it's like they're just
naive or do you think that if we define truth
as something that could be possibly subjective,
for example, if if there's a law that comes
into play that lowers taxes, for example,
and I'm a conservative and I believe that
lowering taxes helps stimulate the economy
or I'm a I'm a liberal that thinks that lowering
taxes hurts infrastructure, for example.
Do you think that if I'm watching, like, a
news segment on CNN or Fox News, then I'm
going to agree or disagree, depending on my
any preconceived notions of this?
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's called confirmation
bias.
Widely studies.
That absolutely is the case.
Yeah.
Speaker 4: Do you think that's kind of contributing
to this idea of fake news?
So it was just hard facts if it was just I'm
sorry, if it was just hard news all the time,
we would kind of just like absorb the news
and make that opinion, you know, honor in
our day to day political lives.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And maybe I mean, you know, it's
very theoretical and it's just not the situation
that we have.
I do think the other problem is that fake
news is being so opinions disguised as news
are different than fake news.
Fake news is a very specific thing.
It's now being applied too broadly.
What you're saying is blurring the lines between
opinion and news reporting.
And that's that's different than fake news.
But I think there's probably more to say.
But but I think, you know, I've kind of given
you my general sense of it.
Speaker 4: I appreciate that.
Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right, there's Victor from
California, very much appreciate the call.
Let's go to a break.
I'm sorry I couldn't speak to more people
today, but I will speak to more people very
soon, that's for sure